this is hit the diamond and that it all
what you were expecting one bit
Wow no we could have predicted it was
just like I I thought there was gonna be
some sort of fight yeah well even it's
called hit the diamond and we know
there's like yellow diamonds the one
sending him out and everything so if we
just serve oh um okay yeah I I like that
uh I thought it was I thought was funny
if I was cute I liked seeing the bomb
connected yeah totally unexpected I I
really like all those rubies I thought
they were adorable I'm wondering if they
got like women or kids to do the vote
because they sound a very kid-like they
were like an evil Girl Scout troop yeah
and I got like for some reason just
there's like a leader and the way the
other four or five like follow that I'm
just like for some reason I just got
girls scared it's like an evil girl
scout and there's something it's like
even though they're all kind of drawn a
lunch troop leader even though they're
all kind of drawn alike there's like
these specific personalities to each one
that they didn't really have to I think
I think it's very safe to say though
that sapphire is the brains of this
fusion operation
yeah but Ruby still had to say you know
you get the ball you know you don't look
at me know that echo that is no that's
very true Ruby did step up the play but
those early scenes are kind of painful
just like sweating it away like like
yeah this is like hi Ruby would be
smarter but then when you see what the
other rubies are like I'm like well I
guess she's the smartest exactly ya know
I thought this was I feel this is a an
unfair representation of Ruby
stereotypical Rubeus out there post on
tumblr your discipline all Ruby lives
matter what about the amazing is DVD
verse just came out with like this
unbelievably races episode that just be
so funny like just out of nowhere like
pride the most PC show you can get just
something like just slams like some sort
of jet
ethnicity whatever Rebecca sugar is
secretly in the owner seems like fuckin
Captain America it was a Hydra now I
don't want to see that happen but it
would be amazing just imagining that I'd
killed see Rebecca sugar just like
throw-in hail Hydra
so I I will say it did shock me like
when not Ruby I'm gonna garnet she like
had like a line in the beginning of his
episode that was like oh that's wrong
I've got lines this episode it's just
like they told vanished last episode
that made me realize that important yeah
I kind of missed them I love the the
baseball like send-off where it's like
Steven pearl
it was Earl remember not for Earl
I'm sorry whatever I like how even sir
the outfits that they wore so I
represented what can't afford it yeah
like pearl kind of had like the
old-timey yeah you go for a look like
that kind of turn-of-the-century yeah so
uh yeah you know what I really like
about again I like it when you just take
characters and it's like just put them
in any scenario put them on a cruise
ship send them to the city whatever just
the characters are strong enough they'll
supply the comedy and the interaction I
felt that's what this was I just love
seeing their reactions just playing this
game and even all those rubies like just
they had these very distinct
personalities and they were just fun to
watch and then even at the end there's a
little bit of a twist like they're
looking for I want forever name though
the one that's up Jasper Jasper
yeah they look for Jasper which is like
what and even though I don't why didn't
they say we're judging that one was I I
don't know and I'm kind of with peridot
I guess that's the sad part for peridot
for such an egomaniac she realizes even
the villains don't want her now they
don't give a shit but I the other thing
is what was with the one Ruby with the
Ruby like Terminator I that was like hey
yeah I I was did we miss something is
she suggested Reiter does she work for
the valiant does she know what's going
on or was she just saying things I think
she just didn't trust him like maybe
that's it just like thank you like okay
like okay I think that's the only thing
I didn't get that at all if the bed is
the case good job as that's my guess but
I don't know I thought was weird too I
don't know I don't know what it was and
why are they looking for jazz stop
singing um when I say um there you go
fuck yeah I know figure yeah yeah it's a
shame they couldn't make this an adult
show cuz I really went Ruby and Sapphire
that I really wanted to say hey stop
focusing up first base and focus up
first base
I really wanted man to be alive but you
know they can't do that no you don't
know how immature I got it we actually
started talking about it's just like
well first base is this yeah so Giza
what is third base yeah we're like it's
like because I know what a home run is
yeah we know what second base is I sound
like a bj you're just going down like
eat now like you know like is it
anything below the belt like so I looked
it up on my yeah it's I think this is
funny bits of baseball gal V I'm getting
this at a huge plot point I don't really
think about the bases I just you you
just run them all not thinking about it
and you know that's how you play the
game the goal the goal is the home run
sorry I just think about the home run so
I was and I wasn't dividing it up and
they individual peas but yeah we kind of
forgot what exactly third base was turns
out we were correct the way I heard it I
was like we were right but I think the
one thing that's how terrible we are as
human beings the logical children's
cartoon show doing that slightly
disappointed in when the five of them
get together all the rubies
they just make one big Ruby and I oh no
does it that does make sense of idea
because they all look exactly honestly I
thought that was awesome yeah the more I
think about it's like that is what they
would look like and it's like the
stupidity was multiplied by five as well
yeah exponential stupidity Neptune well
I didn't you favor ya know cuz at first
I'm like why didn't you do all the cool
funky designs but all of them look
almost exactly alike there's only the
tiniest differ
like in color and the hairs a little
different stuff but you and I like they
just came out and said like going back
to that scene that home plate they just
give it so what is what are they doing
flirting I'm like wow we've got an
actual flirting lesbian couple they're
like in the kids car I don't think okay
with all the leaps and bounds up in me
like in the past year or two I don't
think that's an especially huge this
shows set itself up well enough that we
don't have to think of it that way but
when I actually sat there and thought
about it for a second I'm like when am I
ever even heard a line like that I've
ever kids cartoon well wait what - yeah
like thing Larry said flirting and I'm
like oh my god like hide your children
churchgoers I like that it I like how
they it's like they come out but then
it's not like they ignore it you know
it's one of those things where it's like
they still have this chemistry they will
flirt they'll kind of and it was fucking
adorable
yes no I think yeah well it's uh yeah
and it's obvious they're good for each
other because I think Ruby loans kind of
dumb well that's why I like martyr than
her compatriots but you know and
obviously I think Sapphire has issues so
it's they compliment each other ya know
they do you know what it's love it's I'm
kind of glad wrap I wouldn't
I'm glad we're at that point because I
mean I talked about this in my haunting
review that you know when we were
growing up gay couples would serve like
the new thing to be brought into media
so serve like they're gay and gay kind
of it sort of like evil gay was your
personality yeah your fans like hey
we're Kate where today we're gay we're
getting like that was it or it was like
not acknowledging they exist at all
except saying that person's gay no
that's I as I said I didn't think about
this till after it had happened I like
sat there and it was only like it went
by and I'm like oh that's cute and I
thought it was like wait what is the
last time I like I couldn't even think
of a scene where it seemed kind of
something like that cuz even Korra
pulled it out at the last second yeah
and that's and nobody there's no other
there's no other nobody else in the
group that was like oh they're flirting
like it just so I
like huh I was like that's kind of an
interesting kind of benchmark moment
that came and went and and I'm like I'm
fine with that I would rather it work
that way it just was interesting it
wasn't till after the fact I'm like oh I
guess I don't really see that like often
like it doesn't bother me I'm just like
that's that's cool well and we watch you
know and their personalities aren't the
fact that they're gay like they're yeah
fully fleshed out personalities to be
fair they may be a sexual they're gems I
don't know but that's another
interesting loophole to get around it
because you can do that then and then
make that like I literally seen some
people argue like why do you have to
bring sex into this like they're ASA
Emma come on you know what this is a
metaphor for like I don't I in no way
would have connected any of this to two
women in love because they're jazz-rock
of their germs their bacteria doesn't
count
you know but we watch kimmy schmitt and
this last season they had titus and this
construction worker come together as a
couple and they are polar opposites and
again I feel like we're writing them now
where now it's not just hey write your
gay character like a real person's right
the couple like a real couple because I
love them in that show yeah or just said
I will say this when it came to tight
tightest right yeah yeah when it came to
tightest I'm actually glad they did that
because I did have a kind of a problem
with his characters I was like okay he's
very funny but they definitely wrote him
is like gay that's him like I felt like
they could be like so ya know they
started giving him more of a personality
as and went along and I'm like thank God
because if that literally was like the
only joke I'd be pissed and when he
finally gets involved in this
relationship it has to work through his
own selfishness I'm like okay they got
it they nailed it we're good thank God
from the beginning he was hilarious you
know that frickin Pinot Noirs he did so
so it's not about he's not funny it's
just I'm like yeah this I feel like they
can flush out more with this character
and they have been so beer and yeah I
think that's why I kind of like
like see but it's a broad stroke yeah
comedy anyway so I tend to forgive it
that because I'm like we're not talking
about something that's like really like
super deep it's not a big character
study and it paints in broad strokes and
I like broad stroke comedies so it
didn't it worked but I'm glad they're
doing more with him yeah um I don't know
I just feel that it just feels nicer
because I mean I think really with
anything I'm you can say uh don't do
that or let's try this or whatever but
until you see it experience it and kind
of feel it I I get the feeling like it
doesn't make as big an impact um I I
think that's just one of the ways you
break through like you know it has
barriers and stuff is that you just show
oh like I like these people
I like see either see two characters who
are good people doing good things who
are gay and love versus asshole
characters that is set a terrible
example that happened to be hetero it's
like it doesn't you know it doesn't
matter like if you're good people I
don't give a fuck what your sexual
orientation is say fuck again fuck you
know just don't give a fuck
hey you know I think people they do it
way too much time on their hands yes
said the two people watching but this is
our job as well strangely enough I don't
know but there's there's many pros to it
let's just say I'm not I'm not
complaining I just like you kind of wake
up some mornings just like how'd this
happen but no I I really liked it even
though it's totally the opposite of what
I thought I was again again I thought
was very funny it worked to the end I
but I did have that mode where I'm like
where are they going yeah no I was just
like oh you know it's because the last
two were kind of like very slow and
character-building and stuff it is kinda
nice like here's here's a goofy one
that's not totally ignoring like hey
stuff is happening you know we found how
bad but yeah but it's a funny it's
comedy it's a comedy episode and it's
literally funny and uses the characters
it worked and they didn't go for the
first base reference so yeah
good for them we're the horrible people
yeah I told me what I've done it I will
fought hard for that even though the
censors be like you just can't do that
I'd be like no I'm making a stupid joke
I would be very curious cuz you know its
creators ourselves we know there are
times where we just want to do something
but can hmm I wonder if Rebecca sugar is
like one of those just sweet nice types
that would never think like that or if
there's a partner there she's just like
yeah I totally have loved to have done
that well you always see earlier than
you know to get because sensors are so
tough like they put in other stuff like
much harsher to get other things they
really want pass like we're putting this
into you know get taken out so they're
distracted by this and not the thing
we've really wanted to get by I don't
like the full house effect I don't think
she's sitting there going like how can
that corrupt people with all these nasty
little references but more like you you
work on something so long that's so
sweet and kind of innocent that you know
caves you just wanna be like and then
they totally do it just because you're
so sick of this you can you can argue
they kind of do when they format a
garnet again yeah I guess I know why'd
you have to bring that into heavy very
curious I don't know I know nothing
about the creator we're just think she's
some nasty Bob Saget type oh yeah she's
really nice and just like when she
closed the throat she's like fuck people
like and that's her voice too it's like
if she's got normal voice she sounds
like dr. girlfriend yeah well when I
came up with the idea of the gems music
together it was totally a metaphor for
lesbian sex let's be honest but more
than that it was a metaphor for love
that's one of the fucking this into some
sleaze bull we gotta stop yeah I don't
know where we go you know we we should
not have dropped acid yeah that episode
made way too much sex
because right now you look like
Pennywise the clown and it's beginning
to freak me out
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha stop